hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by thrive
market and i'm going to be taking you on
a little behind the scenes grocery haul
tour
to show you what kind of things i'm
putting in my usual grocery basket
so let's do this
okay first and foremost a quick
disclaimer that this is just what i
bought
this week this is in no way shape or
form
recommendations for any of you for what
you should be buying
everyone's budget dietary restrictions
their preferences their family's
preferences are all going to come
into play when it comes to what they're
going to be buying when they go to the
grocery store
so this is just what i bought this week
it's not necessarily what i buy
every week though i do have some go-to
staples that of course i'm gonna chat
with you guys about
also quick trigger warning i will be
showing nutrition labels so
if you're struggling with disordered
eating or you have in the past then of
course skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey
so my usual subbies are probably like
where
are you because this is not my normal
house and it's also
not my normal filming studio kitchen
either
so we are having some renovations done
at my actual house
um and so as a result our families just
just decided to
rent a little airbnb so that we could
stay safe you know kobe
we don't really want to be hanging out
running around living
breathing sleeping in the same house
where we've got a bunch of contractors
working so
um just to keep things really safe we
are staying at an airbnb
so i've ordered all of my groceries here
today
speaking of ordering groceries i know
that a lot of people have gotten into
the rhythm
of ordering either pickup or delivery
groceries
during covid but me i actually have been
doing this for a really long time i
think as soon as
i became a mom with e i just no longer
had the bandwidth to
do big long grocery shops on the weekend
anymore the thing i love about ordering
my groceries is that
anytime i remember something that i need
like let's say i open the fridge and i'm
like oh
yeah we're running low on eggs i just
add it to my grocery order when i think
about it because if i don't do it right
then
it's gone this makes allows me to make
sure that i actually get all the things
that i need and i'm not making
multiple trips plus it's just so nice to
just
either get them delivered to your door
and then you know you put them away
or just have to run your car down to
pick them
up and you don't have to walk through
the whole grocery store you don't have
to wait in line
it saves me so much time so as a mom
i'm going to be doing grocery delivery
probably for life
but do i miss going to a grocery store
yeah
i mean i would love to peruse the aisles
of whole foods at some point
someday soon when the world is you know
a little much more of a safer place
but until then i'm happy to just get my
groceries delivered
the other thing worth mentioning is that
when i do get all my groceries and i
usually do it on
a monday and i do carve out some time in
that work day
to do some meal prep so you know of
course i put away like anything that
just needs to go back in the fridge or
freezer or pantry or whatever
then i will take some time to chop up
vegetables
steamed veggies for the kids roast some
vegetables for
our dinners throughout the week maybe
cook up a big batch of pasta or
rice something that i can easily put
together
into easy weekday meals that when five
o'clock rolls around
i'm not scrambling i typically do spend
maybe two or three hours just doing some
of these basic meal prep chores
and i don't i know everyone has their
own meal prep ways where a lot of people
do like full meals and then they like
freeze them or they put them into their
little
containers ready to go stack them up um
i love that
i don't do that i'm just not that
organized but i
prefer to do what i call like meal prep
components
all the veggies like roast a couple
vegetables cook a couple grains
maybe cook a couple proteins if i'm got
like chickpeas
rinse them drain them pop them in the
fridge easy to throw on salads
roast some chicken thighs or chicken
breasts uh some tofu
etc that way i've got these meal
components that
all i have to do at the end of the busy
day
is put them together in a bowl with some
sauce and you got a meal
that is basically how i'm living right
now in covid with two kids
but anyways let's talk about what we got
here first
let me tell you about my sponsor thrive
market so
thrive market is an online membership
based market
that aims to make health-based specialty
food products
more affordable and accessible for
everyone basically you do a guided
shopping quiz which will give you your
own set of
personalized recommendations and your
own shopping list
that is tailored to your unique diet
goals and household needs
you can also filter by different diet
goals like vegan or fair trade
and you can do all of your shopping for
groceries beauty
supplements home goods and more members
will save on average about 32 dollars
per month
and thrive ensures that they never
engage in surge pricing
no matter what i also love that they
pack everything in carbon neutral
packaging
that comes from zero waste warehouses
and shipping is free on orders over
forty nine dollars
they even have a new section on their
website for bypack owned brands
and for every membership sold thrive
will donate
another membership to a low-income
family in need
they have one month and 12 month
subscription options so
you can choose the option that best fits
your lifestyle i definitely recommend
going with the 12 month membership
because it comes down to just five
dollars a month if you join today you'll
get 25
off of your first order plus a free gift
so check out the link in my description
to sign up
all right so let's get on packing it's
like christmas
and honestly when he saw this box this
morning and he was
desperate to get into it because to him
when he sees a box he thinks it's a
it's a present he says i'm so excited
so yeah it was really hard for me to
tell him to not open it
mommy needs this for work all right
gotta have some popcorn i'm obsessed
with popcorn
everyone knows it i i could eat this
whole bag just like myself as a snack
i don't love the clean snacks sinful
taste
rhetoric on the bag but i do love the
flavor of these i love the
the kind of butter flavored coconut oil
and the himalayan sea salt just the
combination
i mean you know any salt is good salt
for me i don't need to be himalayan
that's for sure
does this have a bit of a health halo
yes does do i still think it tastes damn
good
definitely so that i'm excited about
oats huge staple in my house e this
morning because i didn't have any
oatmeal yet
he was like where's my oatmeal that's
those are those are
literally the first words that i heard
when i got him
from his crib where's my oatmeal
so yeah that's how my morning started
but we do love our oats here and these
are sprouted quick oats
kind of cool and we know sprouting does
help to enhance the bio
about bioavailability and the
digestibility as well so that's great
and these are thrive market branded
seaweed snacks i'm gonna bring these to
him
he's out for a walk he's gonna love
these these are his favorite
you gotta have snacks especially for the
kiddos
freeze-dried fruit huge staple in my
house
love it for throwing onto you know
yogurt
or on top of your oatmeal but also just
great as a handheld snack for the kiddos
too so
great option and these ones look really
cool this is a thrive market um
brand dragon fruit chips
very cool you know what i gotta bust in
these
have four grams of fiber in the pack
pretty good and four grams of protein
i don't know i've never had a dragon
fruit chips before so let me tell you
let's spread this out
sweet sweet and tangy maple syrup
in a convenient squeeze bottle thrive
so good i'm canadian so we gotta have
our
our maple syrup almond butter and a
squeeze packy
and cashew butter in the squeeze packy
how fun
i go through so much nut butter and i
like to switch it up each week if i do
you know almond or um cashew pistachio
peanut
we're always switching it up especially
because i've started uh
solids with baby o and it's really
important that we're introducing him to
all of the different um nuts and seeds
to that
make sure that we can we rule out those
kinds of allergies early
these this sounds great just it's just
almonds so there's no
additional um you know there's no sugar
or salt added to these
which is exactly what i'm looking for
when i'm serving a nut butter to
a baby so these look great speaking of
nut butter
this is one of e's favorite snacks he
has not had this in a long time
um but i was excited about them these
little peanut butter
mini crackers i mean are they any
healthier than the ritz ones
i don't know probably not but i think
they're really delicious
um and uh and there's three grams of
protein in a pack so i can feel good
about that that's for sure
um it's a little high in sodium but
they're delicious so
me and e these are for us
okay so for cooking of course we need
some like actual
cooking stuff fonza pasta i mean you
guys have heard me talk about it a
million times
we've got the rigatoni and the
tapi have a tapi that's a word i've
never
used before there's 22 grams of protein
8 grams of fiber
i mean doesn't get better than this and
also
they're gluten free if you need a
gluten-free option i think that these
are really great
so as a parent i love them because
i know that if my kiddo doesn't really
feel enthusiastic about something else
on the plate that is more
protein based i at least know
we're getting some good protein and
fiber into him and he's obsessed with
this
loves it i love so he loves the little
shapes and stuff so all that
friends what else we've got some
canned salmon also so great so it's wild
pacific pink salmon skinless boneless
i got the no salt added one that's
really what i was mainly looking for
um just because we know how important
that is
uh when with the little one with oh
specifically i want to make sure that
we're choosing
an option that is lower in salt
speaking of meals i got some taco sauce
because
your girl can't make all the sauces from
scratch anymore it's just not happening
especially
because i'm out of my element i'm out of
my home i don't have all the spices
in the world we gonna take some
shortcuts and i love this taco sauce
it's really delicious
just add this to any kind of ground meat
or a faux meat
in a pan once i've chopped it all up and
voila he's having taco night also i saw
this on thrive market and i was so
excited folks
everything but the bagel seasoning so
this
you know this is going on everything and
i'm going to show you all the things
that i'm going to put this on
which is going to be on that and that
and that and that and that's i'm really
really excited
i like to get a variety of milks as you
can see i'm like i got a lot of milks
going on here
so i got i wanted to try this one this
is the um barista blend
almond milk by khalifa i haven't tried
it yet
this is the macadamia nut latte
so this is also like a barista blend
macadamia nut
shall we try shall we try shall we try
which one
in my coffee or remex two
little coffees jumping on the bed
one fell off and bumped his head
you sing everything when you're a mom so
we got the
almond milk barista blend on one side
and in the other
corner macadamia nut
moo is moot i don't know guys i don't
like strong coffee
my hubby made this a little strong
i don't think we knew what we were doing
because we don't make drink drip coffee
so we're just like
i guess this is how much to add okay
this is macadamia
good still strong what can i do about
that other than add more
almond also good i think i like the
macadamia
but i'm gonna drink both cause this is
the
this is the first
coffee of the day puts you in a good
singing mood oh
excited about this balsamic glaze so
here's what you're going to do
this is my hack this is my kids favorite
food we call it
avocado candy in our house so when the
avocados are ripe
you slice it up into little like you
leave it ha
ha in a half half shell whatever
and then you kind of score it and you
drizzle balsamic glaze
inside or you just put it into the hole
basically and we call it avocado candy
and let me tell you it is my son's
favorite
food he will eat a whole avocado and my
kid is he's small
he he eats like a bird most times but
you bust out an avocado and some
balsamic glaze
he's gonna down it he's gonna he's gonna
have a good
good meal and that means a good good
sleep and that's what all
that's all parents want what else can we
ask for in life also non-negotiable
extra virgin olive oil and this is
thrive markets
uh organic cold pressed from greece
i also love love the cylinder
i don't know it just feels feels sexy to
me
oh i also got traditional balsamic
vinegar if you guys don't know
balsamic vinegar is my my life it's my
favorite flavor my favorite flavor is
acid
and i particularly like the dark variety
of acid
i put it on everything it's my favorite
vinaigrette base
it's life also balsamic on
fruit and then strawberries and a little
ice cream
it's gonna it's gonna blow your mind had
to get salsa
didn't get chips well
it's just gonna have to go on eggs then
until i get me some chips i also want to
try this
this ketchup out this is primal
kitchen's organic
and unsweetened ketchup what is it
sweetened with
i didn't even look i guess nothing
balsamic vinegar
so yeah i mean there's no artificial
sweeteners in it which is great
i'm going to be trying this out on
little baby o
as a nice little dipper we're all about
dips in this house
if you're a parent you know how
important dips are i also have a great
recipe on my blog
for a no sugar added ketchup if you want
to try that
as well pb2 you guys know if you follow
my blog i've got a lot of recipes using
pb2
um i love that it's basically a really
great source of
protein a little bit of fiber in it too
so two tablespoons has six grams of
protein
so throw it in your smoothies throw it
in your oatmeal throw it into
your yogurt i think you guys saw that
hack in one of my videos
but i particularly just really love the
flavor and when i'm baking for my kids
i often replace some of the flour for
pb2 because not only does that provide
the peanut
allergen which we know is important to
be providing that often with our little
ones to help to reduce the risk of
allergies
but also is going to be boosting up that
protein as well
we don't need to skimp on the fat when
it comes to nut butter this is more for
the texture that it brings and just the
convenience of adding protein the same
way you would add protein powder to your
smoothie
it's basically peanut protein powder
that is what it is
now this is something i've never bought
before but i saw on the thrive market
website and i was like
kind of kind of excited about it mama
chia
chia squeeze vitality snack and i might
give one to o
because he is constipated yeah so i'm
going to bring this over to
get get all on one of these because he's
a little backed up
as happens with little ones yeah so easy
i don't love squeeze pouches into mouth
i prefer either onto a spoon
or if baby is self-feeding then i prefer
to put it into a bowl
and uh preload a spoon so baby can
self-feed
that just that's just how i prefer to do
it and so yeah
this is gonna be great so of course if
you are traveling for ease and
less mess i hear yeah a squeeze pouch is
is a godsend as well and then for
spreads you gotta have your peanut
butter and j
this looked really cool it's called fix
and fod
everything butter which has hemp almond
peanut pepita chia sesame sunflower flax
seed
basically it's nut butter on steroids
and i love that as
a nut butter freak especially because
that's you know it's so important when
we're
introducing those allergens like i
mentioned to keep all of those different
allergen allergenic nuts in the mix in
the rotation
regularly so this has a a number of
typical allergens so you know the sesame
peanut and the almond
plus it's got all those grape seeds it's
got eight grams of protein three grams
of fiber
in uh in two tablespoons and nine grams
of monounsaturated fat so we've got lots
of good healthy fat and then this is
thrive markets organic super fruit
blend fruit spread so this is like a jam
so we can do a pb
j with this this one's got um blueberry
strawberry and apricot
and it's actually made with fruit so
there's no added sugar to it so it's
made with
sweetened with fruit juice instead of
adding like a lot of
like cane sugar and things like that oh
my gosh it's like christmas
now we get into the other groceries very
important first and foremost
coffee i can't remember which one's
which
think that's the macadamia let's deal
with this before
it melts because i will be devastated
this is a staple you guys know it's a
staple
this is a must i always buy this every
single week and i go through it
every single week this is ben and
jerry's netflix
and chilled folks the best ice cream
flavor that was
ever created as far as i'm concerned if
you disagree with me
please let me know because if there is a
better flavor than netflix and chilled
i need to know because this has peanut
butter ice cream
with sweet and salty pretzel swirls and
fudge brownies in it
what else could you want what do you
want it's not that simple what
do you what else could you want the only
thing that maybe i would add to this and
sometimes i do
like i doctor it up actually i always
doctor it up is i add a little bit of
dulce de leche
on top and sometimes some score bits as
well if i'm feeling
feisty other freezer staples that i need
to probably
deal with chopped spinach
and we've got some frozen blueberries so
this morning after the
where's my oatmeal e's second bossy
little request was
where's my smoothie and then he had a
meltdown
and a tantrum because i didn't make a
smoothie yet but that's because the
groceries were coming
and now i have them and these always go
in the smoothie it's usually like
a ripe banana um chopped spinach
blueberries
yogurt or silken tofu depending on how
i'm feeling or what's up
i love the silken tofu texture it's so
so good
some kind of milk glob of nut butter
flax or hemp hearts
i think that's usually it sometimes i
throw an avocado in there if one's kind
of going off
but yeah so good okay that is
next coffee i've also got some meat
here we don't need a ton of meat also if
i'm being honest because this is not my
house i'm probably going to order in
more than usual so i've got a little bit
of some chicken thighs and drumsticks
for
especially for the kids they love a good
drumstick baby lead weaning style
is the cutest to see a little child
gnawing
on a like a bone so we do bone in
more fat and goodness for them and i've
also got some
beautiful salmon fillets that i'll
probably roast up everyone loves salmon
kids love salmon it is a fantastic uh
protein
to get those heart-healthy omega-3s fats
i'm not done with the non-dairy stuff so
i also want to try
almond milk creamer haven't tried this
yet but you know what
throw her in there while we're having
coffee
why not have all the coffee oh she's
thick
that's thicker than most creamers like
non-dairy creamers i've tried
almond and coconut cream hazelnut flavor
yes that is what i'm smelling
so yeah there's like two grams of sugar
in this it's added sugar obviously
15 calories in a tablespoon but there's
no hydrogenated oils
that tastes delish and that's really all
i care about
it tastes good also a2 milk so
we drink a lot of milk in my house i
drink non-dairy milk in my
lattes and coffee for whatever reason
but i drink whole milk
dairy milk pretty much everywhere else
adds that protein i just like the
richness and of course
my son e exclusively drinks um
the the the whole milk because it's got
more fat in it
and more calories and it's got of course
the calcium and vitamin d that we want
this is i actually they're a client of
mine so i have uh i know quite a bit
about it
but the a2 milk is what we usually go
with because there is some evidence to
suggest that
folks that have digestive issues when
they consume
a usual glass of dairy milk may
just think that they have lactose
intolerance when in fact it may actually
be
the a1 beta casein protein found in most
dairy products
so this milk just contains the a2 beta
casein
protein so for some people it may be
better better tolerated
if lactose is not an actual issue if
there's not an actual
diagnosed lactose intolerance or milk
allergy
so something to keep in mind what am i
doing more cheese so
baby bells we actually love baby dolls
like my son
is obsessed with baby ales and i like to
switch up the different flavors so he
sometimes says
i want a black one i want a red one i
want a green one now
raise your hand if when you were a kid
you
used to try to eat the wax on a baby
bell
don't lie to yourself don't lie my
husband tells me he used to make wax
lips out of it yeah and i never went
that far but i definitely was
wax curious at a point in my life so the
apple doesn't fall
far from the tree let's just say that he
has he has eaten his fair share
of wax too okay next we've got some
cream cheese this is a whipped cream
cheese variety i'm i'm a jewish mom we
gotta have our
lux and bagels i didn't get bagels
jewish mom fail this is what they call
jewish guilt
i didn't get bagels and i'm gonna get in
trouble for it but
i got the cream cheese and i got the
everything bagel spice and i got some
bread so maybe we can
hack a bagel we'll try but anyways i got
the whipped variety which i
recently got into i think it is actually
lower in
calories than regular only because it's
like got some air whipped into it
phage i don't know leave me a comment
below
i want to know i pronounce a lot of
things wrong and i
try not to feel bad about it trying not
to let this keep me up at night but
anyways i always go with the
higher fat options when i can a plain
greek yogurt
um so this one's got we've got 18 grams
of protein
so i love that and and the fuller fat to
me is so much more satiating
the mouth feel is better if you don't
love greek yogurt because you find it
kind of
astringent and too tangy for you too
bitter
this is a much better option i think the
higher fat it smooths that
all out
my kid is obsessed with tzatziki i don't
know when that started
but he quite likes it dips are king
when you've got kids because dips allow
your children to you know explore foods
that maybe are unfamiliar to them or
maybe are
foods that they are learning to like
because if the dip
is liked uh that's the gateway to get
that that new food that vegetable or
fruit or
or meat or whatever it is into their
mouth
so if he loves a good tzatziki
we're going to put zuziki on everything
so i put that
on everything that is how we roll and i
mean it's made out of greek yogurt this
is actually really great
i'm going to pull rachel ray here you
know how rachael ray like she like
does this it's like part of her thing
where she has to carry as much as she
possibly can
and not all right pantry pantry goodies
we got puffins cereal i love puffins i
don't know it's like
the crunch the texture it's it holds up
in the milk and i also put a lot of it
on yogurt it's a great handheld snack
too
my son loves them so yeah they're pretty
good six grams of added sugar
six grams of fiber and three grams of
protein per cup so
yeah i do i do enjoy me a good puffin
cheerios i've been working with general
mills for so long and so i'm a big fan
of cheerios
the yellow box is just one gram of sugar
per serving and
my son is getting to the point where
he's working on his pincer grasp
what we call pincer grasp so that allows
him to pick up
tiny little things with his with his
finger and his thumb rather than just
like
grab things like like a like a palmer
palmer grass is what he
alright we talked about ketchup had to
get the og
and his buddy frenchy frenchy mustard
very important so these guys
match made in heaven and we can't go a
meal without
drowning it in mustard and ketchup uh
yeah that's taller life it's always like
more ketchup more mustard and then
what ends up happening is that the meal
becomes a pool of ketchup mustard with
like a side
of tofu or carrot but whatever
if it makes it more enjoyable for him if
it makes it safer safer for him
i'm all about condiments even condiments
that have sugar like ketchup i'm okay
with it so just something to keep in
mind moms
don't feel bad about that garbanzo beans
i had to get some um
chickpeas a really great option for just
a fast
easy salad topper to add some protein
and i also
i might make some hummus if i feel up to
it if i find that there's a
blender here which i hope there is
because i got gotta make a smoothie
before i have another tantrum issue
tomorrow you gotta get bread
and i love we love sourdough in my head
in my house
so sourdough is my go-to and i prefer
bread to bagels i'm gonna try to i'm
gonna try to say it
the appropriate way bagels
bagels that's right right uh
they're called bagels bagels
that feels off i don't even know how
it's supposed to sound anymore
i'm losing my mind so please don't bug
me about it anymore okay i know i know i
say it wrong
i don't need to go to speech language
language therapy
i do however need coffee so i really
didn't know what a good coffee
was when i was looking on my like
instant cart um
app but i ended up just because of what
was familiar to me
i got the starbucks so i got a decaf
option for
my afternoon delight and um pike place
medium roast as your basic morning
brew which is what i'm drinking right
now with a variety of
non-dairy milks and creamers we talked
about banza i love the bonsai rice too
my kids love rice and this has five
grams of fiber
11 grams of protein in a serving
so it's a fantastic option and we also
needed something sweet
milk chocolate raisin eggs i don't even
go with the dark things because i don't
like dark chocolate
so i don't i don't even try to make a a
a treat food
or a fun food more healthy by you know
drinking myself through an option that i
don't actually really love
if you don't love dark chocolate and
you're just choosing dark chocolate
because you think it's healthier for you
don't because it's not going to be very
satisfying to you
you're going to go on a flavor hunt so
basically you have
a handful of the dark chocolate raisins
and that's not what you want
so then you go into the pantry and you
plow through a whole family-sized bag of
potato chips but that's not what you
want so then you eat all that ben and
jerry's ice cream but that's not
actually what you want
so then you end up like ubering yourself
uh a a packet of milk chocolate because
that's
actually your style and then you end up
with like a five dollar delivery charge
on a two dollar item
it's happened it has happened before
it's probably happened to you
okay we're getting to the end here also
the end of coffee switching it up
you guys know i'm obsessed with
sparkling water there's not a sparkling
water i have
met that i that i don't like but i
really like this dandruff
yum yum yum and um
i just find they're so flavorful so
because they've got a little bit of real
juice in them so if i'm feeling like
i want just a little bit more flavor
than my typical lacroix
or lacroix or whatever the hell however
you say it
i'm going with one of these bananas i
got a lot of bananas
as you can see we go through a lot of
bananas and when i orders bananas i
order all right i put in the app
uh like a request i say give me one
bunch that's pretty ripe
and one bunch that's green once i get
through this bunch
this bunch is ready to go this one's at
the helm being like
all right all right all right all right
eat me now
avocados we eat a lot of avocados i
talked about avocado candy
we also just love them and
i see your lips moving but i can't make
out your words
and that my friends is because my audio
cutout
technology not always my best friend but
anyways i'm going to
walk you through the rest of my haul
here because the show must go on right
gotta have some avocado because hashtag
avocado toast
also love little cherry tomatoes or
grape tomatoes for snacking
bell peppers are fantastic because you
know they're a low fodmap
option that i totally had grow on me
during my
low fodmap elimination phase and then
we've also got some baby cucumber for
snacking
we've got some sweet little tiny apples
which are really great for my toddler
because
i always find like all these half eaten
apples
all over the house so this way of course
we're wasting less with a smaller
little apple for him mandarins are
fantastic for snacks
also baby carrots i love them raw i love
them cooked the kids have them cooked
i obviously eat way too many of them
hence
the orange palms but it's all good
nothing dangerous
it's just a genetic thing and i've got
some blueberries
i've got strawberries we always have
lots of fruit in the house
green beans are a definite favorite of
everyone i love them just plain steamed
the kids are obsessed with them
little baby o like he could gnaw on a
green bean all day
every day and then finally we've got
some romaine because sometimes i just
don't feel like kale or spinach and i
just want a crunchy
water rich salad and some eggs which are
total staple in my books and that my
friends is all that i have for you today
thanks again to thrive for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on
what kind of vlog content you want to
see me do next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you